the fastest way to absorb news is a
revolutionary app called newsreels i use
it all the time to quickly catch up on
news by scrolling through the reels page
similar to an instagram feed you can
read any story as quickly summarize
bullet points click the link below to
use newsreels for free
all right i'm going to play for you just
a little bit a little bit of another one
of these bogus interviews with employees
from facebook we've now had one or two
of these every single day
the back story of course is that we had
these whistleblower documents leaked
uh we now um actually learned the
identity francis haugen of the
whistleblower on 60 minutes sunday
testified on
monday or tuesday of this week and
facebook has been falling all over
itself to respond to the different
claims including sort of most
importantly we could say
that they know
facebook and or instagram aren't so good
for a lot of people's mental health
and that a lot of the things that do
most well on the platforms are
disinformation and things that are bad
for body image and so on and so forth
and they still allow the algorithm at
minimum if not encourage the algorithm
to surface those things because it
generates clicks and it generates
engagement keeps people on the on the
platform and generates ad revenue as a
result so we had an interview on npr
earlier in the week with one guy who
seemed completely unprepared we had an
interview from cnn on yesterday's show
uh with a woman who was sort of like
denying every claim that was being made
even though they were really non-denial
denials they were very squishy denials
now i have video here
of facebook's global head of security
antigone davis that name brings me back
to uh junior english
antigone davis
who
without really denying that pushing
content that upsets people is what they
do
says it's it wouldn't be logical for
facebook to do it listen very carefully
to what she says it's actually
extraordinarily short-sighted so if you
think about somebody's experience on the
platform if they're having a very
negative experience at some point
they're going to turn away from that
from that negative experience so it to
suggest that we'd optimize towards
something negative for the long term
value of business just doesn't actually
it is illogical it doesn't make sense so
she's claiming it wouldn't make sense to
optimize for a type of content that
upsets people wouldn't make sense
because then people get upset and then
they leave the platform except it
doesn't happen
it doesn't happen partially
because people are sort of addicted to
these platforms and you can endlessly
scroll and see what's the next thing do
i have notifications that someone send
me a message
partially because there's a sort of like
a
slot machine effect where you might
scroll and see something cool or not and
so the variable reward system works to
keep people scrolling and a lot of
people might feel like crap but not
realize it's because of browsing social
media comparing yourself to others and
whatever else the case may be so she
first of all doesn't really deny it she
just says it would be illogical it
ignores the fact that this is a business
model i mean like think about tobacco
the long term tobacco cigarettes are not
optimized for the long term why because
they kill the users okay but in the
short term particularly because nicotine
is addictive you generate a ton of money
so the idea that it's not a it's not a
logical business model to do something
that in the long term hurts your
customers idiotic absolutely idiotic and
the denial is a very very soft and soft
and squishy denial as i like to call it
now
um in the midst of all this remember
facebook also had an outage on monday
facebook has now
told the story
of why they say the outage took place
the outage was the longest stretch of
downtime for facebook since 2008.
to all the people in businesses around
the world who depend on us we're sorry
said facebook facebook shares were down
five percent monday up one percent
tuesday
facebook uh is saying that the issue was
caused by configuration changes on the
backbone routers
and what the changes were
was not said
the changes caused quote issues
that interrupted the flow of traffic
between routers in facebook's data
centers around the world
this disruption to network traffic had a
cascading effect on the way our data
centers communicate
bringing our services to a halt so for
all of those speculating that this was a
deliberate outage in order to try to
smother
the revelations about the facebook
whistleblower
i understand why you think that the more
i've thought about it the less likely i
think it is the amount of
um
reputational damage
that facebook
suffered
as well as
significant number of hours during their
at during which their ads weren't
running there was a financial problem as
well you could say it was all worth it
to smother the whistleblower stuff
but everybody's posting the
whistleblower stuff now anyway so
i am leaning against it having been a
deliberate outage but if you disagree
with me let me know and we'll have more
clips from these very strange interviews
with seemingly unprepared facebook
executives uh on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show